march is national reading month it's
time to bring attention to the
importance of kids becoming good readers
bianca holman reports on where our
students stand and how to get them on
track
it's really hard right now kids did have
loss of learning during coveted time
they did fall back only 41 percent of
students in clark county school district
are proficient in english down from
previous years that's according to an
assessment from the nevada department of
education and a consulting firm found
that our students are an average four
months behind in reading sarah rich is
an educator and business owner of just
right reader she says students in k to
second grade should be reading decodable
books
these are books where they can sound out
the words she says using these can help
make up for literacy gaps and the more
the kids are actually reading books that
feel right for them we want them to be
too hard we don't want them to be too
easy we want them to feel like they're
getting the tiniest bit of a challenge
and it feels good rich says if there are
more than five words a child doesn't
understand then that book is too hard
for them
during national reading month this is a
time parents and guardians can boost
their child's confidence we really want
parents to just celebrate reading with
their child so take some time have a
time every day that is going to be your
reading time and then celebrate have
something special have a chart in your
house that every time you read you put a
star on it bianca holman live local now
rich says parents can do a free reading
assessment for their child on her just
right read website along with
suggestions for decodable books